thank you for joining us i'm john
langler we have several breaking news
stories this afternoon we're going to
start in the centennial bowl in the
northwest valley take a look live u.s 95
is still closed right now after a deadly
accident this morning a driver killed
when a beam fell from the work site onto
the road below and eight news now has
learned the victim was an off-duty metro
police detective mary jane belliesa
joins us live this afternoon to explain
how this all happened mary jane this is
still a developing situation
john that is absolutely right this
deadly accident happened just after
seven this morning nevada state police
had to shut down u.s 95 under the 215.
the investigation will take some time as
there is a lot to look into
state police says a tractor trailer
carrying equipment was driving south
under the 215 when that equipment an
excavator hit a metal beam the beam was
part of the nevada highway department's
construction site the beam fell onto a
car killing the driver
metal beam fell there was a silver ford
passenger car that was traveling behind
the tractor trailer and the beam landed
on top of the ford passenger car
the passenger car was occupied by one
occupant a male adult those beams are
early warning beams to let drivers know
the max height when driving through
construction zones that tractor-trailer
was not associated with the nevada
department of transportation or the
centennial bowl project
trooper wellman says this is an ongoing
investigation and the portion of the
highway will remain closed and won't
open until the early afternoon both ndot
and the driver of that tractor trailer
are cooperating with nevada state police
reporting live from buffalo and u-s 95
mary jane ballissa live local now
mary jane thank you